i mean i got a million basketball
questions for you but i did think it was
interesting that you apologized to women
in your new book
they are the women i've known and know
they are not a number
right much more than their ladies and
they were not to be
treated as a number so i had to
apologize i want to apologize for that
because
i see them as beautiful people not in
number oh that's
a very good attitude ever gotten married
in marriage
[Laughter]
no i have nothing against you my mother
and father were married for 49 years
before my father died so uh i thought
you were to say before my father wised
up
yeah right was your father a tall man
five eight and a half the tallest in his
family right until my older brother came
along then i came along and wiped the
thing over and how tall was your mother
five ten almost
see that's interesting because like my
father was considered tall for his day
he was six foot two and my mother was
five
eight yeah but i'm this giant six foot
five yeah how'd that happen i don't know
how it found but
but my grandfather was supposed to be
six eight and a half years then you
never saw your height as a burden
i never never known right now the book
addresses basketball you you're down
you're down on basketball aren't you i'm
down on on sports today and basketball
in particular because they've diluted
the game so so much now
the book is who's running of the asalam
and it's being run by
various forces that we don't even know
about you are so articulate about this
game
why have you never coached uh that's uh
not my bag and you know it's too much uh
too much lack of being in a box and not
being able to go anywhere because the
players today are so powerful
they sign these contracts for seven
eight nine ten years and
you have to put it with them because
they're there so it's almost impossible
to you can't really coach
absolutely and was it true what i said
about you uh being perhaps like a color
commentator on the sports
uh broadcast they're afraid of someone
like you actually commenting well
they've
they've asked me a lot of times to do a
great cbs
but i wouldn't want to because of i'm
sure they would blurt me out you know
and so those kind of things
because because you say negative things
about some of the players i would say
the truth not negative things they may
be negative in the way that that's the
way they're performing
i see and when you see this did you were
you a guy who got a lot of endorsements
in his time when he i've got a lot of
endorsements in my my time so i really
cannot complain
and what about when uh you see a guy
like michael jordan do you ever say to
yourself am i better than do you
consider yourself
yeah is he better than you were you know
uh it's uh different eras you know i see
michael jordan as this
i see all the money being paid for these
guys are out there you know
right and i think that michael jordan
should get about ten percent of every
guy's contract
right because he's made basketball he's
made basketball exciting i mean what it
is and so when
young guys like this boy iverson who
comes out from philadelphia and says
that he has no respect for uh anybody
whatever he should be taking his head
off to michael jordan and staying here
whatever whatever you want don't you
think he's gonna same kind of guy though
well you know we're that's years ago no
one remembers that
back then basketball was not as popular
a sport well no back then
basketball was trying to compete and
just get noticed right right so you
couldn't get that kind of money that's
what i helped i helped basketball
getting but
wilt brought that kind of recognition to
basketball
thank you rob and you your rob you might
get a date